[Music]  he told me to do nothing before and I  listen to you I'm not doing nothing  again and just like that Daenerys made  the decision to fly her three dragons  beyond the wall to try and save John  Snow from the undead army but Sunday's  game of Thrones didn't end there in fact  we're still pretty rattled by this  shocking moment  [Music]  but just as we were about to mourn  Viserion the night king touched his  lifeless body and this happened it seems  Danny's precious baby is now a white  Walker or a white dragon to be specific  make sure to watch Game of Thrones next  week for the season 7 finale and no  doubt more jaw-dropping moments with the  ice dragon  you